who are safer drivers men or women well
according to a new survey 55 percent of
adults feel that women are most
responsible for minor fender benders
while 78 blame men for most fatal
crashes please note that the percentages
in these pie graphs do not add up to 100
percent because the math was done by a
woman
for those of you hissing at that joke it
should be noted that that joke was
written by a woman so
now you don't know what the hell to do
it
[Applause]
no i'm just kidding we don't hire women
i consider amy schumer the funniest
person on the planet
if you take me out of the equation
no i meant means
[Laughter]
well premier magazine's list of the 100
most powerful people in hollywood hit
the newsstands this month in an odd bit
of ranking demi moore was ranked number
28 while
her breasts were ranked 20 and 21 so
and finally weekend update would like to
congratulate madonna who gave birth to a
beautiful baby girl last monday the baby
weighed in at six pounds nine ounces
making it the fourth largest object ever
to pass through madonna's birth canal
in an interview out this week
demi moore says she would like to have
another baby this time a boy to go along
with her three daughters and two huge
breasts
for years hillary rodham clinton has
told people that she was named for the
first man to climb mount everest sir
edmund hillary but as esquire magazine
recently pointed out sir edmund did not
climb mount everest until 1953 six years
after hillary was born however the first
lady does have a good explanation for
the discrepancy she loves to lie
[Applause]
you've admitted that you're lazy i think
you've read six books in your life i've
read six six what kind of a woman would
be attracted to you do you think
well i have a lot of money
[Applause]
and in entertainment news ellen
degeneres and lover anne hesh have
announced that they want to have a baby
however their plan has hit a snag
they are both women
it is not possible
to have a child
there's this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board
wow
all right do something with that you
freak
i i bet the board has spelt
b-o-r-e-d demi moore is wrapped filming
on g.i jane
in which she plays a navy navy seal
combat officer moore says that in
contrast to other hollywood portrayals
of women in the military her character
will have giant breasts
[Applause]
finally in this in milwaukee wisconsin a
man allowed his eight-year-old daughter
to take the wheel of his car and an
accident ensued that damaged seven other
cars and injured six people which once
again proves my theory
women can't drive
name five great women writers on
saturday night live
um
i would say uh right now we have paula
pell who's great uh we have um
uh
hey you want to take a call from joel
no i don't want to embarrass you you're
having trouble getting past one
actor bruce willis is filming his next
movie the broadway brawler in wilmington
delaware meanwhile his wife demi moore
is taking a break from movie work saying
she wants to spend more time with her
huge breasts
hollywood prostitute devine brown has
written a book describing in lurid
detail exactly what she did with hugh
grant the book sells for twenty five
dollars but for thirty five dollars
she'll show you
after closing out a successful first
season the wnba is considering several
changes to improve the level of play in
the league next year among the proposals
extending the playoffs increasing
salaries bringing back the three-point
line and replacing all the female
players with guys
like i try to make it fast like if i see
a girl drinking at a bar right i'll go
up behind her i'll go i'll go i can get
us a bottle
[Laughter]
and that doesn't work very often but
sometimes right yeah i want to get right
then i get the lady i turn off all the
lights in the room so it's pitch black
and then i lay down on top
for 5-10 minutes
[Music]
the wnba officials expanded to 10 teams
this week adding franchises in detroit
and washington dc but before you get too
excited about the new additions to the
league remember all of the players are
still women
they stink at basketball that's the
problem
oprah winfrey's longtime boyfriend
steadman graham has written a new book
called you can make it happen a nine
step plan for success
step number one
become oprah winfrey's boyfriend
[Applause]
[Music]
then the other aider just hang around
how to capture a man's heart and it it's
for women and it says all these rules
that you have to follow and you will
capture a man's heart and the rule
number one have huge breasts
[Laughter]
yeah that guy likes it
is the first lady a compulsive liar
though it's beginning to look that way
in an interview on last night's 2020
intended to promote her new book it
takes a village mrs clinton folded under
tough questioning by barbara walters and
admitted that in fact it does not take a
village
and furthermore that she was aware that
it does not take a village when she
wrote the damn book
[Applause]
i'm thankful for women opponent there
you go greatest creatures on earth
that's all right we'll get behind that
one i think women are more intelligent
than men
[Applause]
also
uh conan without women there would be no
cookies
here we see president clinton looking
for something anything to hug besides
his wife
pop singer madonna was outraged this
week when a tabloid photographer snapped
her picture while she was breastfeeding
her new baby apparently the baby was
blocking her nipple
real estate mogul donald trump announced
this week that after three and a half
years of marriage he is seeking a
divorce from wife marla maples according
to trump maples violated part of their
marriage agreement when she decided to
turn 30.
unacceptable
frightening moment this week for first
lady hillary clinton her plane enroute
to the former soviet union was forced to
make an emergency landing when it was
discovered that a frayed wire in the
engine was causing serious malfunctions
the president was said to be furious and
demanded an immediate investigation of
what went wrong with operation frayed
wire
actually you know when i was on saturday
night live when they wanted to do
weekend update they wanted me to do it
with a girl they wanted to be two people
look at this right here
but i said no
but i said no
well i said it was very funny because it
was a big argument because they go
because lauren goes no no no like lauren
has all these theories and he goes no
you'll bring uh if you get a girl she'll
bring you'll bring her the comedy and
she'll bring you the sex and
ginger and fred and i'm like what
weren't they dancers
i didn't know what he was talking about
but i said i don't really want to do it
with somebody like just get let frank
can do it or something you know yeah and
but he was he really wanted me to do
with a lady and then uh
and then steve martin was the host that
week was really funny and then uh lauren
goes let's hear what steve has to say
about you know
so then steve martin comes comes in and
he goes norma norms we're talking about
having maybe norm and a co-host do it
you know do it with a girl what do you
think of that steve and then steve goes
ah man he goes i i did this award show
last week and he goes they put me with
some stupid actress and i have we had to
you know
present the award together and she
wrecked everything so he kind of said so
he pulled it out of the fire yeah